they make it their business to mind your
business
California chefs and bartenders are
annoyed about a new law that forces them
to use single-use gloves or utensils
when handling food like sushi and fresh
fruit if they get a smoker who would
have quit smoking to continue smoking
that's event in Chicago ban baking in
public new law cheats ecigs like regular
cigarettes so lawmakers figured they'll
improve public health by making it
harder for smokers to quit smoking and
if they wreak lammer eyes the act of
smoking that's maybe no duals crackdown
is coming next but hey big thanks to
Tenafly New Jersey viewer Daniel
Guglielmo who found that nanny of the
month in his own town it kind of felt
like the Grinch was at my front door the
Alberto family says they checked with
the police and fire department then
headed out with some neighbors to spread
holiday cheer by lining the street with
decorative luminaries neighbors from all
different backgrounds of their children
out to help that later on Christmas Eve
someone arrived at the alberto his home
no it wasn't Santa it was Mayor Peter
Ruston at the front door telling them to
take down the lights turns out one
neighbor was offended that it had
nothing to do with religion for us it's
a tradition of bringing a people on our
neighborhood closer together
Alberto ended up taking down the lights
and the mayor ended up apologizing after
receiving a bunch of angry emails it was
unfortunate that this incident took
place on Christmas Eve Salah granted the
month on Twitter submit your nanny
nominees and click here to watch another
episode
you